حركه النهضه هو نحكيه واليوم على عادل
تحايل علي في اموال عن قيمتها زميليرات
398 الف دينار
وكان معناها ايدي الي بتساعد فيه
عبد الكريم هاروني موعد مع سيف بن رحومه
ليحدثنا عن اكبر عمليه تحيل تعرض لها من
قيادي في حركه النهضه سيف ما زال تحت
تاثير الصدمه منذ سنه 9 10
بعد عملياته تهديد والهرسله والاعتداءات
الماديه من قبل عناصر محسوبه على تنظيم
الاخوان بمجرد توجهه للقضاء مطالبا
باسترجاع امواله ومقدما وثائقي وادله
وتسجيلات وسكوك بنكيه لكن دون جدوى يتسلط
عليه حركه كامله والحركه عندها نفوذ
الدوله اليوم بعد ما يتسلط
عليها راشد الغنوشي يعني طلب منه هو كيف
شكلك مش نظيف العقد هذه العقده هذه غير
قانوني تظهر هذه القصه كما يحكيها صاحبها
طريقه عمل تنظيم الاخوان في تونس في
التحيز وتبييض الاموال اليوم وبعد فتح هذه
الملفات صدرت بطاقات ايداعا بالسجن بحق
قيادات من النهضه وتحجير سفر وتجميد اصول
بنكيه مع ادراج نجل راشد الغنوشي بالتفتيش
ومع شروح القطب المالي في التحقيق في
قضايا الفساد وطبيب الاموال التي تعشريه
الاخوان يتسائل المهتمون بقضايا مكافحه
الفساد عن امكانيه تورط هياكل الدوله في
الفساد وغياب الاراده السياسيه لمكافته
وحازنا في مساله مكافحه الفساد بسيفه عامه
وخاصه مثل تبيض الاموات وهذا شفناها حتى
في الاحزاب السياسيه لمده يديها
لمهربين ودخلوا المسجد
يعني رجال اعمال ف مشمولين بمحاكمات
ومعتعافي المؤسسه القضائيه تظهر ارقام غير
رسميه ارتفاع عدد قضايا تبييض الاموال من
70 قضيه سنه 16 و 2000 الى 2200 سنه 21 و
2000 مع تصاعدي المطالب بتحقيق المحاسبه
قبل فتح باب المصالحه
سيا ضربه موجعه اخرى تتلقاها منظومه
الاخوان في تونس تمس اخطبوطها الماليه
ستحسد رؤوسا كثيره من حركه النهضه لقد
يعني حل هذا الحزب قضائيا واغلاق قوس
الاسلام السياسي في البلاد بعد العشريه
السوداء وفقا متابعينا وليد عبد الله
العربيه
تونس